Bạn có muốn AI tự động đăng bài lên Facebook cho bạn mỗi ngày
ở trên AntiGravity 2.0 mà không cần phải mở app,
không cần code, hoặc là không tốn một đồng không?
Trong video này mình sẽ cho bạn thấy cách mình làm điều đó bằng
tính năng mới nhất Schedule Task ở trên AntiGravity 2.0.
Tính năng này vừa mới được ra mắt tại Google I.O.
2026. Mình là Nam, kỹ sư phần mềm cấp cao tại FIS Fortune 500
và mình cũng là người quản lý và điều phối team.
mình đã tự động hóa toàn bộ công việc đăng bài lên Facebook bằng
AI Agent. Sau video này bạn sẽ hiểu thêm về các bước để tự
động đăng bài lên Facebook. Như hình ảnh đây,
tự động đăng bài lên Facebook bước 1 sẽ là Setup Agent.
Facebook API, tạo ứng dụng trên Facebook Developer,
cấp quyền và lấy Access Token.
Bước thứ 2 là tạo Skill nội dung bài viết và Post
Request thẳng đến Facebook Graph API.
Bước thứ 3 là lên lịch, tự động, tự động lên mạng,
tự viết bài và tự đăng thẳng lên Facebook. Ok,
mình sẽ cho bạn thấy tính năng Schedule Task. Đây là tính năng mới
được thêm vào của AntiGravity 2.0.
Khi bạn mở AntiGravity 2.0 lên,
bạn sẽ thấy sẽ có Schedule Tasks. Mình đang có 2 Tasks.
Task đầu tiên của mình là Daily News, thì mỗi ngày nó sẽ chạy
Daily Report để báo cáo, tạo một bản báo cáo cho mình mỗi ngày.
Đây là mình có Skill Daily Report.
Mình đang có 2 Skill Setup. Skill thứ đầu tiên là Daily Report,
thì mỗi ngày nó sẽ lên mạng, nó sẽ tạo một bảng báo cáo
dưới dạng HTML Daily cho mình mỗi ngày.
Và skill thứ 2 là dựa trên cái bảng báo cáo đấy,
nó sẽ viết một bài viết cho mình. Ok,
Nó đã chạy cho Nó chạy cho mình ngày hôm nay 3 giờ trước.
Đây là, Nó đã chạy bảng báo cáo Daily Report đây.
Ngày hôm nay là ngày 7 tháng 6.
Để mình mở lên xem nó như thế nào nha. Đây là bảng báo
cáo nó đã tạo cho mình ngày hôm nay. Đầu tiên là nó có
những vấn đề chính là Google ra mắt mô hình mới,
Gemini và API cũ của DeepSync bị khai tử và Windows Autocopilot
Scout. Bây giờ dựa trên bảng báo cáo này mình sẽ dùng
skill nữa của mình là daily report để tạo một bảng bài
post lên Facebook. Bây giờ mình sẽ chạy cái skill Community Post
Generator Skill cho ngày hôm nay. Đây mình sẽ chạy như thế này,
xem nó chạy được không.
Nó tạo một bài post lên Facebook cho mình bằng cả tiếng Việt và tiếng Anh.
Đây là bản tiếng Việt đây. Đó, nó sẽ như thế này cho ngày
hôm nay và các tin tức chính về Deepseak,
về Google và về Microsoft và đây là bản tiếng Anh nữa.
Đó, đó là nó đã tạo một bài post,
Theo các bạn thấy, nó thiếu một bước, bước cuối cùng là post bài
lên Facebook và đó chính là bước mình sẽ làm ngày hôm nay Thực
ra mình đã có skill này ở bên OpenClaw rồi,
giờ mình thấy AntiGravity 2.0,
ScheduleTask khá là tiện lợi nên mình sẽ tạo một skill y hệt như
vậy. Skill này còn xịn hơn vì có cả browser là sub-agent.
Skill này của mình sẽ Bây giờ mình sẽ mở skill ở trên OpenClaw
nha. Đây skill facebook poster skill mình đã có ở trên Đây
là bản OpenClaw của mình.
Cách skill này hoạt động, thứ nhất là nó sẽ nhận nội dung bài
viết hoặc là ảnh hoặc là video nếu có. Và nền tảng mình chọn
sẽ một là Facebook hoặc là Instagram,
hai sẽ là dùng access token của mình để xác nhận xác thực với
Meta và gửi một cái request để post cái bài lên Meta,
lên Facebook hoặc Instagram. Nếu nó có lỗi thì nó sẽ bảo lỗi cho
mình. Đó, đây là skill mình đã tạo cho OpenClaw.
Bây giờ mình sẽ copy cái skill này qua AntiGravity 2.0 và
mình sẽ bảo nó xem chạy được không. Đây là mình đã đã copy
qua cái folder trên AntiGravity 2.0 của mình.
Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo nó chạy xem nó có chạy được không nha.
Bây giờ mình sẽ mở AntiGravity 2.0 lên và mình sẽ bảo là hãy
tạo một skill mới ở trên Agent Skill cho cái project này của mình.
Và skill này phải giống như cái skill Social Media Poster
Skill của mình và test xem nó có hoạt động được không.
Bây giờ mình sẽ chạy xem Ok,
nó bảo là nó đã tạo thành công một cái skill Social Media Poster
cho mình Để mình check lại xem nó có hoạt động được không nha
Check thử và đây nó đã tạo một skill mới Social Media Poster Skill
cho mình Bây giờ mình sẽ thử xem,
nó sẽ post xem bài này cho mình xem Hãy post cái bài Community
Post Draft lên Facebook cho mình Ok,
nó đã tạo cho mình thành công Skill Social Media Poster.
Bây giờ mình sẽ sử dụng Skill Social Media Poster để đăng cái bài
cho ngày hôm nay. Bây giờ mình sẽ bảo nó dùng Skill Social Media
Poster cho ngày hôm nay xem nó hoạt động được không.
Hãy dùng Skill Social Media Poster.
Cho nó dùng, Hãy dùng Skill Social Media Poster cho ngày hôm nay xem
nó hoạt động được không. Ok,
nó đã đăng thành công lên cho mình rồi. Lên Facebook cho mình để
mình mở, đứng lên xem nó có hoạt động không nha.
Đó, đây là bài tiếng Việt, nó vừa đăng xong.
Vừa đăng xong cho mình luôn. Và mình không cần phải mở,
không phải tự đăng gì hết. Đó. Để đăng được như này thì
bạn phải tạo một cái app ở trên Facebook
Developer đây để lấy quyền và lấy access token.
Mở lên bạn vào developer.facebook.app Bạn
tạo một cái app mới, create a new app và mình đã tạo như
là Nam Post đây và mình đã tạo cái ad
này, rồi mình đã lấy cái quyền truy cập ở
trên Use Cases và mình create một cái Create and Manage
Ads with API và Manage Everything on Your Page Và mình sẽ
vào Tools, Graph API Explorer Và
mình lấy mấy quyền truy cập như là Page Manage Post,
Page Reach Engagement, Page Show List Và mình sẽ lấy cái token này
Cái token này sau khi mình lấy xong mình sẽ có quyền tự post
bài lên Facebook cho mình Dựa trên token này và API
request của mình thì nó sẽ tự động post bài lên Facebook cho mình
luôn. và mình không cần phải mở app hoặc là ứng dụng hoặc là
gì đó. Đó, đó là skill post lên Facebook cho mình.
OK, mình đã có skill post lên Facebook,
bây giờ mình sẽ tạo một cái form để mỗi ngày tạo một cái
task ở trên Schedule Tasks. Mỗi ngày vào 9h sáng,
nó sẽ đầu tiên, nó sẽ tự động lên mạng tìm kiếm thông tin
mới nhất về AI, sau đó nó sẽ sử dụng skill viết bài,
và cuối cùng nó sẽ chạy cái skill
post lên Facebook cho mình. bây giờ mình sẽ tạo một cái New Schedule
Task nha. Bây giờ mình sẽ tạo Daily Post Facebook.
Xong rồi mình sẽ setup vào 9h sáng
Và mình sẽ tạo một cái form là bước đầu tiên là mình sẽ
sử dụng Daily API Report
Generator Skill để chạy cái skill để lên mạng lấy thông tin mới
nhất về AI Automation Tiếp theo,
mình sẽ sử dụng Community Post Generator Skill cho ngày
hôm nay. Bước cuối cùng là mình sẽ chạy Social Media Post Generator
Skill cho kết quả từ bước thứ 2.
Nó sẽ tự động post bài lên Facebook cho mình.
Bây giờ mình chạy từ cái form này xem nó hoạt động như thế nào
nha Bây giờ mình sẽ copy cái form này và mình vất vào cái
whatsapp page mình đang sử dụng Để xem nó chạy được không Ok,
nó đã post 1 bài khác cho mình ở trên facebook Xem nó post
gì nha Đây mình mở nó lên xem nó post gì đây Đó,
nó post 1 bài y hệt như vậy luôn Đó.
Đó nó đã post 2 bài liên tiếp cho mình. đã có một AI
Agent tự động đăng bài lên Facebook mỗi ngày cho bạn bằng AntiGravity 2.0
từ việc lấy tin tức. Viết bài rồi đăng lên page tự động.
Bạn lên lịch một lần là nó có thể chạy mãi mãi.
Bạn không cần phải code, không cần phải phí,
không cần phải mở máy. Nếu bạn thích video này thì hãy Like,
Subscribe cho mình nha ở trên kênh PieLikeClaw.
Mình sẽ làm nhiều video về Anti-Gravity 2.0.
Cảm ơn bạn đã xem. Thank you!